booyah Mandarin desert ceccolini go Punk
to Polanco a bra to achieve its
observance a committee visited several
images from the Granton Hippolyta Cuba's
be transferred tsuitachi of Bolivia
shadow sporangium debated Ragnar pies
for informal watch Jeff solution Islamic
residue repeating Cellini whiskey
whiskey Karthik both nazarov Norris
Ravitch at IKEA dot estas aqui Costas
Navajo system or a strategy electronic
night not a GoPro sham each zap shot
recipe card dango Sylvania issue chill
Bishop a sorceress Travis Arabic residue
repentance Sally prophetess Robbie -
Tara's an etiquette snack on it's the
bottom birth of Rochelle's Iranian was
so visible in terms of community
circumstantial own industries are
entering politics retransfer final
federica mogherini bare the brush thank
you madam president this is a critical
moment for Bolivia moment when maximum
restraint and the strongest possible
sense of responsibility is needed both
inside and outside the country
delicate moments like this require firm
rejection of violence and the highest
level of statement shipped from all as
you know the 20th of October Bolivians
voted in presidential elections that
were marked by several irregularities
these has brought bolivian citizens to
the streets it has led to violence and
civil unrest across the country three
people were killed more than 100 were
injured the current unrest follows
months and years of tensions regarding
the country's political future as you
all know president Morales took the
controversial decision to run for a
fourth term in office with the approval
of the Constitutional Court but after
failing to win a referendum to amend the
Constitution itself tensions escalated
around the election day when the polls
closed a preliminary result counting
system showed that none of the
candidates was likely to win enough
votes in the first round and that the
second round was the most plausible
outcome the system was then blocked
for some 20 hours and when it resumed it
registered a sharp change in the initial
tendency the Supreme Electoral Court's
announced president Morales as the
winner in first round by a margin of
just 0.5% of the votes but the Vice
President of the court resigns during
the counting process protesting the way
the process was managed as a consequence
demonstrations and violence broke out
across the country five local election
offices were set on fire the most
powerful civil society organization
called for a general strike the
Organization of American States had
deployed an election observation mission
to Bolivia and it declared in a
preliminary report that the best option
would be the two leading candidates
moved on to the second round run-off
this assessment was endorsed by the
european union's election experts
mission that we had sent to the country
and by several EU Member States we also
expressed this position publicly on the
24th of October given the widespread
mistrust the Bolivian government invited
the Organization of American States to
carry out an electoral audit the
government agreed that the results of
the audit would be binding the audit was
supported by some EU member states with
experts and also with some funding the
preliminary conclusions were announced
last Monday the audit identified a
number of irregularities and concluded
that the election results should be
annulled and fresh elections should be
held as soon as possible in the
following hours the opposition asked
Morales to resign and so did the head of
the Bolivian Armed Forces
president Morales together with the vice
president and number of Ministers
decided to step down and he has sought
political asylum as you know in Mexico
according to the consultation based on
the absence and the Constitution sorry
based on the absence and resignation of
president vice president and presidents
and first vice presidents of the
chambers the second vice president of
the Senate would be the next in line to
assume the presidency in a caretaking
role until new elections
European Union supports an institutional
solution that allows for a caretaking
interim leadership to prepare for new
elections and to avoid a power vacuum
which could have dire consequences for
the entire country
in these very days and hours we have
been active through our delegation in La
Paz that I want to thank to create a
space where governments opposition and
civil society could meet and discuss a
way out of this situation
we are actively supporting the mediation
organized by the local Catholic Church
to help the Bolivian parties agree on a
peaceful path that can lead to new
elections this mediation has already
produced some first results in easing
partially tensions and avoiding a worse
escalation of violence at the Foreign
Affairs Council last Monday updated the
foreign ministers of the member states
on our work on the ground we discussed
how to best support Bolivia in
preparation of the announced election
we're assessing the possibility of a new
European Union mission to the country
and of assistance in the election of a
new Supreme Electoral Court Bolivia is a
very important partner for the European
Union in these years we've built a
strong political cooperation and we have
developed political dialogues where we
discuss all issues including those where
we have disagreements for different
views we deployed an election expert
mission to the country and we have
several projects in support of Bolivia's
strong civil society in the last 14
years Bolivia has certainly changed for
the better
poverty has dropped access to basic
services has improved
indigenous people have increasingly been
included in the country's public life
and all these successes must be
preserved and this can only happen
through a peaceful political solution
that respects the Constitution and the
rule of law and that can bring the
country to new timely credible elections
which faithfully reflects the will of
the Bolivian people
Bolivia can come out of this crisis and
consolidate its democratic institutions
it has all the potential to continue on
a path of democracy sustainable
development and social inclusion well
coming weeks will be
the european union will continue to be
at the side of the Bolivian people as
we've done through the years and in
particular in these difficult moments in
the country's democratic life thank you